foreign
[Music]
champions of this realm can do nothing
to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that
was in the last few years the wizard
gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers
all right here's the situation
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt Us
children's told the power of the Gods
eat from our father's call okay I feel
like maybe I should be writing all this
down
your world will not survive this
you want these Powers come get them hey
police
we have one job to do save the world
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I can't do this take my powers back you
came to me so you would take them back
right
searching for worthy champion
you've known exactly what must be done
really what are you doing I have to do
this we end this now
we do
started from the planet we're here
[Music]
now we're here
I'm an idiot
it's showtime
I don't deserve these Powers if I'm
being honest like what am I even
contributing
there's already a superhero with a red
suit with a lightning bolt on it
so manly and Batman so cool and I'm just
me
[Music]
I feel like a fraud it doesn't matter
um anyway the wizard gave me superpowers
but then everybody got super powers but
there's everyone going
to fight crime okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep it together
[Music]
you understand I'm a pediatrician
right come on
the fate of the world depends on it
[Music]
children's taught the power of all the
gods
[Music]
look I might not have as much experience
as you because I'm not super old like
you but I've seen all of the Fast and
Furious movies Lady it's all about
family
family guys that was a signal
[Music]
the world will not survive this
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I think I know how to fix this dude but
I really don't
everyone can be worthy let's give it a
chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
I just threw a truck and a dragon I love
my life
[Music]